[Music]
three
two one action what up guys welcome back
to off the record where we talk about
whatever we want and today's segment is
ask an expert and we have kevin a real
estate agent here and
uh one question i wanted to ask you is
you know when people buy a house they
always say like
oh it's an escrow an escrow or the
escrow but i don't really know
what escrow really means like what are
all the steps that happen in an
escrow and how come it takes like i
don't know a month
very good question so in california we
use escrow
depending on what state you live in it
could be something else
oh for real yeah some use attorneys who
just
literally do the same thing as what
escrow does but we in california have
escrows right so what the hell is that
escrow yeah
why is it a crow yeah that i don't know
uh but basically what happens is you
know the typical process is you go out
there you look at properties
you like a property you submit an offer
and it gets accepted
right so from there uh a buyer
and a seller has specific things that
they have to do right
one of the first things that you would
have to do is once we get an acceptance
there's a thing called we call the
initial deposit
it basically secures you with the
property right so
at least you have some money in the game
right as as opposed to hey like in five
days later you're like
peace i don't like this property i'm out
right the seller can't hold you
to the property so that money in the
game if that guy changes
their mind to get to keep it potentially
oh right depending on
how the contract is formulated and the
process that comes through but
first thing after acceptance is we bring
in the deposit it secures the buyer to
the property
that money goes to escrow right so the
agents don't handle
handle that money the seller doesn't get
that money yet it just goes into a
neutral third party between
the buyer and the seller um that money
gets held in the escrow account
and then the buyer typically will have
things that they have to do
right because right now they only see
the property
it looks good feels good they want to
move there
but is it a good property right like it
could have termites could have termites
so you do all the checkups during the
escrow time
that is correct so in the offer that you
write typically you're going to have
a specific amount of time to do these
specific actions so the biggest ones are
going to be
inspections and the inspections could be
just what we call general home
inspection termite inspection
you can check the sewer line depending
on the age of the home you can have an
electrician or if you're
planning to remodel right you might want
to bring a contractor out how much is
this going to cost me
is it going to be out of my budget
within my budget so there's all of these
things that we have to do within a
specific amount of time
right now if you go through that process
and you find out okay
uh this is just too much work for me or
there's too many things wrong with the
property
then of course you can cancel in that
deposit that you put in you can get that
back as a buy is that typically like the
biggest thing that happens
is something severely is wrong with the
property yeah or you can find out
somebody died in the property you're
like well i'm not doing this
is that why sometimes in you can change
the price
after you find out stuff and you're just
like yeah hey man you didn't tell me
about the broken pipes it's gonna cost
me like 50 grand correct correct and
they'll be like okay i'll give you a
discount
and there could be things in like the
disclosures that a seller fills out that
a buyer has to review so there's going
to be a stack of reports and disclosures
that a seller you know fills out about
the property and gives to the new buyer
to review so if they've had tons of
plumbing issues that could cause like
let's say a red flag for the buyers
they're reading this or as their agent
reads it with their
with their client so then they can be
like hey this is something that
you might have to deal with because if
it's happening with them most likely
it's going to happen with you unless
they've corrected it
right or if they did correct it did they
have a professional licensed plumber
come do it where's the invoice i want to
make sure that it was done
right so you have that plus then on top
of that most people are going to get a
loan
right so if you're getting a loan you
want to make sure even though you've
been pre-approved
first it doesn't guarantee that you're
going to get a loan to purchase the
property because you could have [ __ ]
up your creditors
you could have or you could have gone by
a car right in the meantime
and then now you just owe too much and
you're going to get less of a loan
because i love going for it like that i
just got in my nest girl now i'm going
to buy a car now
like in a week in escrow whoa
yeah so they look for that like debt to
income income ratio right so they're
always going to look how much money you
make
what what's your expenses wow balls on
some people
so you have that see that nice car
though dude
true um and then the other thing is
because most people are getting loans
there's gonna be a thing called an
appraisal
right so the appraisal is basically the
bank
stating okay if you buy a house for a
million dollars
right the bank wants to know because
they're giving you money is a house even
worth a million dollars right just
because you're willing to pay a million
dollars
doesn't mean it's worth it so let's say
it's uh
worth under a million then what happens
so or it gets appraised for under a
million yeah so
in the contract the way it's set up is
if the property doesn't appraise for the
uh purchase price that you're paying
then you as the buyer have the right to
cancel
and you can get that deposit back i see
right but it really depends on how the
offer is
negotiated because in this competitive
marketplace that we're seeing right now
um people are paying a lot higher than
what
yeah because people are just trying to
grab anything and everything that they
can right because we have no
inventory um so some people are waiving
the appraisal contingencies
so if you do that you know if the
appraisal comes in low you still have to
purchase the property
right but it's very case by case what if
it's
um appraised for more than what you're
paying for is that just called like a
bargain like that yeah then
you you you have instant equity right
when you move
does that ever happen it does um not as
much
lately just because it's been so crazy
with people
just over bidding on properties is this
a
la phenomenon or do you think this is
happening all over america
um la for sure california for sure as
well too just because we're not building
at a rate
even as crazy as many people going out
of the state
um we're still not building as as quick
enough for the population so when you
say
inventory that means like there's not
enough housing for people
that that are here in california correct
because our population is still well
i think there's a couple different
facets to this one
is there's a lot of red tape with
government agencies uh making it much
more difficult to try to build
and um that has just increased the cost
for
developers right so because of that
what's gonna happen is you're just gonna
add more costs on to the end product
so if you do that guess what prices are
gonna go even higher and the margins get
smaller as well too because if you don't
have a market for it
it's not going to work so the developer
are the people
that want to create homes and stuff
correct
and then so because it's so difficult
for them to build new homes in
california
for them to be able to do it it's these
big guys that can
that can actually afford it correct i
mean it's just going to increase the
cost of actually developing the product
so if you're going to increase the cost
what's going to happen the price goes up
but at least the politicians in
california already have their houses
though
yeah there you go yeah they don't have
to worry about the restaurant i don't
mind if no one else has a house if you
build more
their their value could go down for
their houses so i understand why they
don't want to do that
why would they want to drop their own
prices the other
thing that we saw pretty heavily or i
saw pretty heavily whenever i would talk
so you have a lot of these baby boomers
who have these huge houses
right kids are gone like all the people
in pasadena right
exactly where it's like like why is this
house worth two million dollars but it
looks like a like 100 200 grand house
out of state
correct um so what we see a lot with the
baby boomers the ones that have these
huge houses
you know there's a thing called prop 13
which basically keeps their property tax
rate so they bought this house like
in 1970 for like a couple hundred
thousand their property tax is really
low
right so there is a prop uh prop 60 and
prop
90 which allows a person 55 years or
older
to sell their property and then they can
buy something of equal or lesser value
and they can actually keep the same
property tax that they were paying
oh wow so they could buy another like
a million or two million dollar house
but pay the property tax at their old
house like that
if whatever they sell their property for
right so let's say they bought their
house in 1970 for 200 000 they're paying
like a couple thousand in property tax
if they sell their house today right
let's say it's a million dollars and
they buy something a million or less
they can keep the same property that way
oh cool if they're within the same
county
so la to la county that sounds unfair
there's a couple where they'll allow you
to do reciprocals different counties
but the realtor associations actually
put a new bill out there
so the big problem was was a lot of
people were willing to sell their house
but the problem was they couldn't find
something
with equal or lesser value oh right
unless they move like super far away or
something correct but if they move out
of state then it doesn't have it doesn't
work
right if you move out of the county it
may not be a hundred percent
so a lot of those people that i talked
to was like i'm not gonna sell my house
because
i'm at fixed income at that point right
so they just end up
like i'll just hold on to the property
plus the other thing is some of them
have made so much money
on their homes they don't want to sell
it and pay taxes
i see right so i think those are a
couple of the big dilemmas of why we
don't see
one is of course just the developers the
cost being too
too expensive and then two is just these
baby boomers they're not they're not
moving they're not moving
right so then what happens is we just
gotta wait till they die
and then maybe get at a discount
uh we still got what 20 years until they
all start
people are living longer that's like the
big dilemma if i have a million dollar
house in pasadena
like you said yeah i put that thing on
[ __ ] rollers i take it out of state
and i sell it do i have to pay
california's attack you put on a bunch
of lies
yeah that sucks sucks dude yeah but
california did pass the legislation over
the last uh
ballot so now the new law could be is
it's a statewide thing so it's not a
county thing yeah
and then the other thing is is you could
actually so there's like a hybrid model
and they they formulated after i believe
it was like florida
uh where you can do it before it was
like a one-time theme now i think
there's you can do it up to like three
times
um and then the other thing is if you
buy something for more
you can actually there's like a hybrid
model so you can keep your original for
let's say you sold it for a million you
can keep that original 2000 let's just
say in the previous example
and if you bought a house for like 1.3
then they'll be like that new rate
right so then it's it's like a little
hybrid model so then it still allows
people to do it and they're not they're
still able to capitalize on on some
savings
yeah today's video is brought to you by
carol
care of is a wellness brand that makes
it easy to maintain your health goals
with a customized
vitamin plan that helps you feel your
best today and supports you
long term what's really cool is that
care of is super transparent about the
research and sourcing behind each one of
their products
and your recommendations come in daily
individually wrapped packets that are
perfect for getting back into the
routine because i know
you know building a habit it's hard when
the
actual doing of it is difficult so when
it's daily package and make it
convenient it's that much easier to
stick to your routine
yeah and what i like about this is they
have this easy five-minute quiz that i
personally took
and it's like a tailored approach to
your unique health needs and for me my
goal this year
is to be able to sleep more and what's
cool is like they'll ask you in
different things like
lifestyle diet health concerns and like
if you're vegan they'll make sure that
they can have the right things for your
lifestyle
or whatever right and for me i was like
i want to focus
on sleep and making sure that i take the
right supplements for that
so um that i thought was pretty amazing
how
a lot of people based on what their
goals are
uh they can provide that for you so
that's super awesome and you can make
taking better care of your health a new
year's resolution this year
with this super awesome code to get 50
off so to get 50 off your first care of
order just go to take
care of dot com and enter the code off
the record 50
that's 50 off your first care of order
go to take care of
dot com and enter the code off the
record 50.
damn that sounds pretty crazy there's so
many like the more you
get into it there's like all this little
detail stuff that you got to know
if you were governor of california
what's the first thing you would do to
help
bring down home home prices home prices
probably let the developers
actually develop right because but if
you bring it down then
would people go into outrage like what
the [ __ ] i bought much i think you
probably do it at a specific pace where
it's not going to be like detrimental
like like in 2005 or 2007 when we had
that
big crash right it was just because it
was just over supply people were just
building like crazy
um and then it just impacted right real
estate the basic
i always say basic 101 of real estate
supply and demand right
you can cover supply and demand you can
pretty much dictate how the market moves
right and the average price for the
nation
is what 300 000 is probably somewhere
around
so if you want to balance things out
then
that's pretty outrageous because it's
more than double what
other people in the states have yeah but
it makes sense because we have a
concentration of
a ton of people in la county it's like
what almost 20 mil or something
out i don't know it's over 10 mil though
right so
but la county is huge but if you go to
let's say
fresno or or you know central valley or
all these other places california
there's a lot of other places that are
just
uninhabited that's because people want
to move here and become waiters and
waitresses
and become active oh that do that too
yeah
some states have incentives like come
move here and we'll help you with your
down payment like pay 10 g's or
something i mean it's all lifestyle yeah
right like what lifestyle do you want
what convenience do you want
and is it worth it right i mean they
always say we pay that weather tax
that's why we have
that's true but is the weather tax worth
it [ __ ] no
no i'm a lot of people are out of here
yeah
so yeah are you seeing that and where
are they going typically so
the biggest is i see a lot of the
retired people
um they like to move for whatever reason
to arizona
right now do they have zero state income
tax too or not i believe so those are
zero but i mean over there i think they
can just get a lot more than comparative
if you go to nevada like vegas or
even texas so it's cheaper than nevada
in arizona yeah depending on what parts
you want to go to i like tucson my
financial advisor was saying a lot of
people like a lot of the retirement do
like to go to places with zero state
income tax because the minute you crack
your retirement open
uh the state could just come in and take
their 10 or 11 or 13
oh wow so it's that's why like people
like going to florida nevada or arizona
yeah yeah those are the biggest ones
that i see though nevada for sure
um texas and then uh arizona i haven't
seen so many
many take like the trip all the way over
to florida florida
i think people want to go where it's um
familiar yeah because i do see a lot of
people from new york moving to florida
well i see a lot of people actually from
new york moving here to california
oh wow no [ __ ] yeah because real estate
prices are a lot cheaper you get more
for what you get just like how we a lot
of people here are moving out because
they can get more so they see us as the
cheap state yeah because they're so on
top of each other
um and then a lot of the jobs are on
coast to coast
too right so i'll see a lot of people
moving from east coast over
to to west coast like if they worked at
i don't know
like goldman sachs and or one of the
major
banks or something like okay i've seen
even like netflix people
coming over right a lot of riders are
moving over
as well too yeah so what's the next step
in
escrow after you get it appraised and
inspected so appraise inspected so
talking about like bringing the price
back down so once you do your
inspections you know
now the full uh picture of the house
right is it good is it bad or there's
things wrong with it
um at that point then you can
renegotiate on price if there are things
that are wrong
um but there's two ways you can do it
you can either have the seller fix it
right before you move in or you can say
okay i want x amount
off and i'll take care of it on my own
once and that
is pretty much all tidied and buttoned
up then the next process is you get down
to the closing part
which is the lender approves you for the
loan you're good to go
they'll send out the the stack of papers
that you gotta sign your life away
sucks that's part of 30 years so [ __ ]
hard literally it took me i think like
30 minutes to sign all the papers yeah i
had to do i did it for an hour and
20 i think because it was me and nikki
both going back and forth are you
reading every page
no it was just taking forever i don't
know why i just look at the person well
it's not even the person it's like the
notary right correct and you're just
like
i think i trust everything that's
happening
why don't they get on docusign or
something you so they're trying to do
that
they're trying to actually do that there
are some states that actually allow for
electronic notary yeah california i
guess we're just a little bit slow we
like to be difficult
uh but they are trying to work on that
so then you can do it especially with
kobit
so you can do it electronically i feel
like our government's like
40 years behind all the time
like they just got a website running or
something
what's the most complicate like escrow
is usually three weeks or
uh anywhere between if you're financing
like 30 to 45 days
is the typical time frame if you're
paying cash i mean i've done it as
quickly as like you can do it seven ten
days
right so let's say you have a buyer and
a seller that's both a pain in the ass
and they have so many things they want
to like negotiate on
yeah can it go past the 45 days or no or
everything has to get taken care of
within this
that's what the contra contracts will
stipulate are those time frames
um does that always happen in real world
there's always like here's what the book
says and this is what real life is
right so it doesn't necessarily always
happen that way but of course you always
want to be cautious because
if you don't perform on specific things
there's
you know there's always a cause and a
reaction to it right
so if the other side wants to play
really hard ball if you're not
performing on let's say
your due diligence time for inspections
they can send what we call notice to
perform
they send a notice to perform and you
guys aren't you know abiding by the
timeline then the seller can cancel you
same thing with closing as well too if
you don't close on time
whether it's the buyer or the seller
either party can send one of those
notices to performs or when we get down
to closing it's actually a demand to
close escrow
and if you can't do it within three days
then whoever initiated that
action could actually cancel you out
right but of course usually when we get
down to that
three days yeah former fixer correct but
usually when we get down to that point
um everybody's trying to hold the
transaction together right because
nobody wants to start
everyone's whether you're a buyer
whether you're a seller right so
that's when it's really important where
the agents come together work out the
differences because you know seller
might have one opinion buyer might have
one opinion
you want to kind of formulate okay
what's going to make everybody happy
right because
you fall out yeah then you got to go
through this whole process all over with
another person
right and you just have no idea what's
going to happen at that so that's why
it's helpful to have the agents because
they kind of like like
mediate and correct smooth things out so
earlier you mentioned like a
no contingency deal which i've been
seeing a ton
like when i was trying to get some um
investment airbnb
properties people were coming in
and they're like buying a cash no
contingency and then
they would get it like immediately
correct and i'm like man how do we beat
these guys
because i'm worried that we get a place
that's overpriced
but also there might be termites there
might be whatever
so um in that case do we just wait or
like what would you do
in that situation i'm a big believer if
it's meant to be it's meant to be
there's no point in trying to force
something right because
there are some things that we try to do
and we're just like ramming it in there
and
it just never works out so i always say
if it's meant to be it's meant to be
yeah plus when you go out there and you
make no contingent offers i mean it's a
huge risk if you have no reports up
front
yeah you don't have anything i mean in
san francisco they got really crazy
because of the whole tech boom up there
right you have all those vcs just making
killings on monies and you see home
appreciations just go crazy up there
they were doing a lot of non-contingent
offers but most of the agents set it up
where
here's a report up front here all the
disclosures up front so at least you
know what you're getting into
as opposed to going in completely blind
right so if you go and completely
blind out i would always say it's not
the right property right unless you're
willing to take that risk
and that risk could be huge right
because or if you're a contractor
yourself right like you can walk in and
you are the inspection
exactly but there's only so much you can
still do with just visually seeing you
just go
is a lot of these homes were being
bought with the same no contingency
stuff right
and then um they'll give you a like that
escrow period or whatever but they're
like
whatever you find that's on you correct
and then i was like people were still
buying them dude
yeah crazy inventory right yeah
inventory it's like and we're not even
talking about
la we're talking about up there in the
mountains yeah yeah
i mean that's we're seeing it in a lot
of parts of the country just because of
the no inventory
but i mean is it worth it because let's
say you got to redo the whole plumbing
or maybe the foundation is off and
that's twenty thirty thousand
you already paid like a thirty thousand
dollar premium and now you gotta dump
another 20
into it uh for the normal person if
they're not an investor they probably i
mean
remember we were talking about just like
three and a half percent down payment or
not even having 20
down you have a big issue like this how
are you going to fix it
and if you don't fix it and you can't
wrap that into the loan so it's like 30
j's up front out of pocket right so if
you don't have that
and you have that issue you don't fix it
guess what's going to happen it's just
going to get worse over time that's true
right and we're talking about
what half a million 800 000 a million
dollar property
right so it's not something that is like
really lightweight
so in your case like um
in a crazy time like this unless you
have like a deal that
you feel comfortable with you just wait
until things calm down and then you
start purchasing or like what would you
do
well i think with a lot of buyers right
now they know they can afford so much
right so i think it's really coming down
to
being okay with what you can buy right
now so
a lot of people do look at that i'm
going to be here for like 30 years this
is going to be my fair
forever home which is true to a certain
extent but most people on average
probably change houses within every
seven years right
really yeah i think the actual stats
always been roughly around seven years
they get tired
yeah or there's changes in lives right i
mean how much look how much our lives
have changed in a year
yeah right um so there's that you have
to kind of look at right
everybody always wants more right you're
like okay i can afford a million dollars
but the 1.2
look a lot better right that's true if
you get a raise or something yeah so i
think you always got to
be within your means of whatever you're
going to purchase um and especially as
crazy the market
is going like if you're know you can
only afford a million dollars and you're
looking at a million dollars guess what
those are going to get pushed to like
1.1 or higher but speaking of that right
so
everyone there's a lot of buzz about
real estate being in a bubble right now
what's your take on that
so compared to our last crash so i i was
really young
in the industry at that point 2008 i was
like three years into the business so i
didn't really understand it but looking
back at it
i mean it was like a triple whammy i
always call it right because you had
people that were purchasing
a lot of people back then you can
literally buy 100 financing as long as
you had a heart rate you got a loan
and you didn't have to put any money
into it so people that could yeah
freddie mac were buying homes yeah
because they had special
we call it 80 20 back then right 80 20
loans so you had one lender give you 80
and you had another lender give you 20
wow right so you literally came
zero dollars to the table there are even
lenders you know there's closing costs
whenever you buy a house
yeah so those escrow fees those lender
fees and so forth
they even had lenders that would be even
willing to pay for your closing costs
back then
wow so literally zero dollars out of
your pocket and you can go buy a house
i missed that bubble a lot of people
also got loans what we call interest
only right
which isn't necessarily a bad loan you
just have to strategically know how it
works
utilize it correctly right so they were
paying just the minimum they're just
paying the interest on
on the on the property so when those
loans readjusted and it was principal
plus
interest right they're like whoa our our
payment now is like three times what we
were paying before
so those people definitely couldn't
afford the house at that point so they
lost it to that
plus we also over built at that time
right
and then on top of that then we had the
whole economy crash
so that's why i say it was a triple
whammy so is that going to happen
in this market i know for sure the
qualifications is like 10 times stricter
than what it was before like they go
through
everything and anything in your credit
scores and like history and all that
so make sure that you're qualified right
um right now on um
because i'm going through the process
with the nevada house yeah and the loan
officer over there like would even ask
me like what's this
17 payment in your credit card correct
and i see you don't ever use this credit
card correct
and also never said i just that's my
only fans
only fan subscription they're really
like trying to see and then really study
your pattern before they
allow you alone yeah because back then
it was there's these things how we call
it stated programs we still have stated
programs today but like they were just
so loose state is basically i make this
and they're like okay right oh [ __ ] they
kind of have that
now they kind of have that now but it's
a lot more stringent than what it was
before so i don't see that happening
because that
that triggered a lot of the properties
coming out uh onto the marketplace where
people couldn't afford right and that
created this excess supply that we had
right now is just literally
we haven't been developing at the pace
of our population in california at least
people are getting well qualified so i
mean nothing lasts forever right so i
think it really is gonna
hinder upon what happens with our
economy right
moving forward i mean they're pumping a
lot of money into
our economy but we might get a third
stimulus plan coming out
um i think inflation is going to happen
so if you look at historical cycles if
inflation happens
real estate prices skyrocket right so
even more than now
yeah so will that happen i don't i mean
we're in
such a weird time because should i hold
on to my house
i'm about to move yeah i mean we're
inside i mean because look at the look
at the stock market right does any of
that really have
solid fundamentals no it's just money
being pumped exactly
so that's where i think the divide is
getting much bigger
so will we have that crap there's got to
be a correction at some point because
affordably after i sell
i hope so too affordability is just
going to get to a point where it's just
nobody can afford it right
because it's getting to that to that
level you know
[Music]
do
you